wir haben heute einen exklusiven termin
bei dem wohl aussichtsreichsten
kandidaten für die bundespräsidentenwahl
hier wohnt er im fünften stock naja ist
ja auch das höchste amt
[Musik]
ach du scheiße gebaut aber für dich
kommst du mal voraus der ideale
bundespräsidentschaftskandidat aber du
weißt doch gerne und immer die
urlaubsfotos mein vater ihn als
zukünftiger bundespräsident werden sie
dann ja auch im schloss bellevue
einziehen glauben sie dass sie sich dort
wohlfühlen werden
natürlich wird man fahre ich da wohl
vielen bergbau auf altenbetreuung
eingerichtet gibt das reiseverhalten
jeden tag geführte reisen mit dem reha
seine wahlhelfer geworden kann ich
vielleicht auch alleine antworten
natürlich können den vater alleine
antworten werden
gauklasse mal über freiheit gesprochen
du kannst über freizeit sprechen im
prinzip die ganzen reden
[Musik]
hinter wird nun die offizielle
pressekonferenz der martin sonneborn
seinen vater als offiziellen
gegenkandidat frank walter steinmeier
präsentiert so sieht man doch mein vater
79 das ist ein sehr gutes alter für
einen bundespräsidenten
das deutet auch dafür uns nicht
jahrzehntelang zur last fallen
sie war früher einer seiner vorgänger
man wohl den glaube ich auch frau merkel
und seinem geschickt hat
haben sie auch über anderen kandidaten
nachgedacht selbstverständlich werden
zuerst überlegt an personifizierten
gegenentwurf von vater staat neu
aufzustellen liga alle spenden an
hamburger tief größe aber derart
abgeräumt und wir haben über die krone
ab aufzustellen den hätte ich sehr gerne
als konkurrenten für steinmeier gesehen
arbeitet noch zu jung der sieg nur älter
aus für eine vier jahre lang gefoltert
vor den containern wegen steinmeier mein
vater nie jemandem container sitzen
lassen
[Musik]
was unser staat jetzt braucht es weniger
mutti und meer himmel hav sonneborn ist
so einfach und damit gebe ich zurück zu
herbergsvater und über welt können